a real warm spot for mat Martin loves what he
brings C oh great chance but ilas sokin makes
the save on Andre poot and this is a big time stop
by soken Devil's heavy on the for chck they create
a [Applause] turnover Riley pinches down keeps the
puck moving Clutterbuck to the front save van and
he turned away a second attemp on goer Glides it
across to M barzel again doson takes it straight
away barzel the one timer redirected wide of goal
PA Mar was there in front and got a piece of it
doson Glides it one time score Bo Horvat has
his six of the season and the Islanders lead
now the Islanders move that puck around pretty
nicely gets all of it marzel to pulock over to
B hor at and he wires this one just over the
glove of Vtech here's Jack of the circle down
low centering feet kicks it and the rebound goes
high so heater had the first crack at it and then
brat sent the rebound over the Bary change of
direction from Mike Riley played 10 games with
the ruins last year two with Florida this year
before he was waved this is his 342nd career
game McLoud with his steel McLoud scores Michael
McLoud from Center all the way in and we're TI
at [Applause] one the Devils were able to catch
the Islanders in a line change let's take a look
at the million doll replay brought to you by the
New Jersey Lottery remember anything can happen
in Jersey it ends up being a partial two-on-one
as we see Holtz driving the net Michael McLoud
gives himself a better shooting angle gets to
the middle he's a right-handed shooter coming
down the left side Corvette tracks it down moves
it behind that and barzel is there Glides it back
to the blue line and Romanov again Corvette a
spinning shot kick save vanic he Smothers the
rebound and hops on top of the loose Puck as well
Hefty 67% this year wins the face off and knocks
It Forward Alexander Holtz with some space he
shoots and oh that's a good good save Mercer and
tley came together on him it moves to poock back
to the front and Van sticks the pat out to get it
away from Nelson to Foley to the other way it's a
two onone Jack Hughes with merer Dawson's in he's
got Devil's go in the end and take the
lead Bullock and he shoves it down low B up
the safe and the devil's in quick transition
position when they're at their best using their
speed they go two on one the other way beautiful
on the same page once again yeah he shoots this
Puck so well he can beat a golender from anywhere
with that velocity and oh behind the defense
barzel was Fresh Off the Bench and he ties
the game he was all alone there as the Devils
were basically going five on four but it pays
off for the Islanders and it's 22 the devils try
and make a play but unfortunately they don't look
at the pass that's a heck of a stretch pass for
the Islanders and Barelle when he has time he's
not going to miss too much and he goes under
the glove over the left Pad but you see the
Devils get caught nobody picks up barzel did he
come from the Islanders bench I think so I think
an Islanders player had the cloud takes it Off
the Wall tries to wedge it out it's held in by
Scott Mayfield cek Glides in go sends it right
back for cikis and it trickles in clb backhanded
it as it was in the high slot and 32 Islanders I
mean he was falling to his knees and that was a
pretty nifty goal actuallyy of giving up goals in
short order this season and it's a good keep in at
the point Devils can't get settled and Their Own
Zone as far as who's on who but watch this play
his go makes a pretty good play he pulls it from
the backand of the forehand little unfortunate
but Bill can't happen giving up goals in short
order like that regardless how they transpire
just has to be more awareness that's the bottom
line here's barzel again finds the trailer and
Riley in his debut Islander game puts it on
VTEC is there barel and horat have two of the
Islanders three goals they're out on the ice now
orbat peels off for a change as JG Pou comes on
and moves it to Romanov at the Blue Line sends the
slot great chance in front and it's a goal for JG
Pou barzel just redirects things that you've
got to got to get better at watch as that puck
comes back to the point you see p slips in
behind the devils and barzel just redirects
the Romanov pass right to p no chance for
vanich on that [Applause] one but it's
P's that rookie year for Blake was at 9899
by the way here's merer to the front Hugh
a backhander oh soken got him another
a really good save there merer across
Hugh again Jack Hughes puts it in and the
devils are within one [Applause] [Music]
Jack Hughes would not be denied on this ship
backhand opportunity on a nice feet for Mercer
right here and good Hustle by Brendan Smith
terrific job getting to that loose Puck after
the good chance look at that quick release as he
slings it to the net Puck is on in Wast no time
what a shot short Side by Hughes Devil's back in
it great short side shot in this period the only
goal of the period to make it a one goal game now
it's Michael McLoud who scored the first Devil's
goal he Glides it all the way across HS PS and
it's saved by soken to P he's in the offensive
end finds the trailing SE and ther he shoots save
Soki rebound whack that and Hughes couldn't get
a stick free he was tied up well to pully back to
Luke Hughes now Jack Hughes takes it he's already
scored once today slides it to defley L moves
it to Jack Jack shoots save remat SC ni he ties
the [Music] game great Puck movement simplistic
the one time Drive the door step for the rebound
it's Nik heer to bang at home you see a little p
movement between Luke and Jack and then the past
and I like the fact they didn't try to get too
fancy get pcks to the where's n he's sure it's
a four and three a little more time and room and
he's right in front and he has an easy one off the
rebound there that fell right in the blue paint
after the blast from Jack Hughes [Applause] here
that is a monster goal Michael McLoud accelerates
the offensive end tries to cut down the middle
shoulders around pulock keeps the puck alive
ball shoots it bouncing in front rebounds Miss
ctis Lazard th it to the front and the devil's
[Music] lead Lazar with 21 seconds to play
unbelievable as it looked like this game is
going overtime and what a great Rush right
from the neutral zone by Michael McLoud Kevin
Ball makes sure he gets it through it's a dirty
goal in front as that puck is deflected off
bodies and Curtis Lazard does just enough to
get it past the goal line one more look and
right there oh baby what a goal and is it
huge it's a two- goal comeback for the Devils
21.5 seconds left in this hockey game he gets
it out to the neutral zone two seconds now one
there's the horn and remember this night when
you tell the story of this season Devils come
from two goals down in the third and win by four